what's going on everybody welcome to
part four of the web development with
Python and Django tutorial series in
this video what we're we talking about
is views and templates so really the way
that most of your pages are going to be
served is via all the things to do with
the MVC or Model View controller
framework where you're dealing with your
models you're dealing with models or
your views or basically interacting with
your models and then the controller
obviously for the URL so now we're kind
of gonna bring all three of those things
together for the very first time whoa
let's get started so I'm gonna pop into
my site and actually everything's
already open so everything there's a
basic illusion of where we left it off
last time so right now our homepage is
still this and instead what we'd like to
do is work like I said we're kind of
modeling this after Python programming
dotnet so we have a little bit of a ways
to go so the first thing that I'd like
to do is maybe just iterate over the
tutorials right now our tutorials aren't
very long so we should be able to just
like show the tutorials on the home page
without you know taking up a ton of
space so the way that we can get get to
doing that is basically I mean we've
already got the controller dot bit done
for the home page because if we come
into here obviously we're serving a page
already right so here we've already done
that so it's already including this
almost looks like yeah we're not even in
the same URLs let's go to the main URLs
cool let me just close that one all
right anyway
here's our real home page it just says
views dot home page so that's the one
that we actually need to modify so views
dot pie home page right now we're just
returning a simple HTTP response but
instead what we're gonna do next is
actually do a render of an actual
template so lots of stuff to cover for
sure so the first thing we're gonna do
is move this and we're actually just
going to replace that with a render
render and in render there's basically
three major things that you're gonna
pass / render well really - but most
luckily all the time like three anyway
first you're gonna pass the request
itself now not all the time not every
time anyway much of the time and
actually is probably since this is being
passed most of the time you're not gonna
see people named these I tend to see its
requests the template and then the
context is passed very infrequently do
people actually name these parameters
but I'm gonna name them just for now
just so everybody understands what these
parameters are should you see them so
then you're gonna pass template name
this is gonna be main dot home dot HTML
and then finally context so this one you
may not always have but you're likely to
have this most of the time and I'm gonna
say it's tutorials and I'll explain this
in a moment don't worry tutorials and
then this would be a tutorial daunt
objects dot all so so this is just the
request that gets passed here you're
just bracele always gonna have this this
is so you can reference things inside of
your template to do with you know like
your user and stuff like that then
you've got template name this just tells
Django where to find this specific
template to be rendered then we've got
the context this is what we want to
basically pass to our template and we
can actually reference tutorial objects
all now via the variable name tutorials
so that'll make more sense when we
actually make this template because this
template doesn't actually exist so can I
add a new oh I can't can't I who I can
so I'll just do it inside of here so
we've got main we'll add basically main
we'll add a new folder templates and
then I'm gonna do another new folder and
I'm gonna call this main cool
did that work I feel as the oh you know
what okay I gotta open it okay cool and
now we've got main now nothing is in
main I'm
say new file interesting I thought I
could I guess I'll have to save as or
something anyway what we're gonna call
this is its home dot HTML and um hello
there let me go file save as cool home
dot HTML okay great
save that I'm gonna come over to here
and save this and okay save that let's
just make sure that worked didn't worked
name tutorial not oh right right right
right okay again a little ahead of
ourselves basically the reference
tutorial objects to all we have to
import it so we're gonna say from period
models we're going to import that
tutorial model I'm getting a little bit
ahead of myself but I want to make sure
that template works okay it does all
right so now in this template here let
me explain something real quickly so if
we look at the path to this template
it's probably really small on your
screen but basically we're saying main
templates main home why are we doing
that well whenever we reference
templates Django is gonna look in all of
your apps for the directory called
templates the problem is a lot of apps
might have like a template called home
or maybe main dot HTML or header dot
HTML or you know think of all the the
iconic names of like the main page that
you might have there's a lot so there
might be overlap in happening there yes
that's a word and so the way that we can
overcome that is by just inside of our
templates directory making another
directory and the typical convention is
just to call it the same name as your
app to me I'm still kind of surprised
that this is commonplace in Django still
I feel like template name you should
just do something like I don't know main
colon the template and main there would
be the app and then that would be the
template of that app I wish they would
do that I just like I said I think this
is kind of silly too
to do it this way but basically what
Django does is it compiles all the
templates so you could in theory of
overlapping template names especially
when you're using like other people's
apps and you didn't go through all their
templates to make sure there was no
cross crossing of names so anyways this
is how we do it like I said I feel like
that's kind of weird that that still
exists today but that's the Django way
I'm just used to Django being so supreme
and everything that they do that this
feels weird
but anyways that's the way it's done so
we are now rendering and let me just be
Pepe here and I'm just gonna do this
actually get rid of that anyway coming
over here to our home dot HTML let's
talk about a couple of things so inside
of Django's templating it is very
similar to Jinja to templating I don't
recall I think at one point it was Jinja
- and maybe at some point they
transferred to their own templating but
I might have been wrong all this time
and it's always been its own templating
but it is very similar but just know it
is not the same so but certain things
are the same so for example if you want
to reference a variable you use these
double curly braces right and you pass
this variable and then if you want to do
some sort of the logic you'll do these
like curly brace percentage sign logic
and then you end the large logic that
way the other thing of note is if you're
gonna do a for loop or an if statement
all this kind of stuff you start with
four and then you would end you have to
actually specify the end of the thing so
you'll see what I'm talking about in a
little bit actually a believe you I
don't know if you can get away with no
space but I believe you do end for no
space anyways we'll do some real
examples here in a little bit so so the
first thing that we should do is like if
we go to this views we're passing these
tutorials anyways under the guise or
under the variable name tutorials so the
way that we can and what we want to do
is iterate over them so the way that we
could iterate over those tutorials is
indeed with four loops so
or we'll just call it toot in tutorials
I don't think I capitalized the T let me
go back and check that real quick
no I didn't okay so for a tutorial and
her for toot in tutorial and then we
want to end for now
what we would stay is like for example
we could just say tut and that will give
us like just the object right to be and
then print tutorial and as you can see
they're just kind of in line with each
other and again
this is because we change don't forget
that string method so before remember I
was saying what this was for if I was to
comment that out
that's kind of gross hold on let me fix
that okay come over here Boop
see you see this like tutorial object
one tutorial object to that's like
totally meaningless to us so that's the
reason why we do this dunder string
method here because as we iterate over
them should we ever do that it's it's
more clear what it is but the next thing
is of course that's a little hard to
read so instead what I'm going to say is
we're gonna encase this in paragraph
tags so that should give it its own
online entirely save that come back to
our website to be print tutorial so
these are the tutorial titles we could
get even more fancy dancy because we
could say tutorial dot two toriel title
then we could come let's just do loop
and tutorial published published and
then tutorial contents and then why
don't we just issue a couple of breaks
just be like some blank lines save that
come back to our website refresh
beautiful okay so the next thing is this
is kind of ugly it looks it's like
actually HTML but clearly it's been
escaped HTML and in fact if we view the
source we can see sure enough that's
escaped right we can see the actual
codes that would generate that so how do
we how do we handle
this well just like Jinja - we can use
the safe flag so under a tutorial
content we can do a little bar there and
then say safe and this just says hey
this is safe you can actually render
this HTML you wouldn't want to do that
everywhere in this case the only people
who can publish a tutorial would be a
super user like an admin so that's
totally fine but of course if you have
like a forum or something like that you
would never want to let the forum post
be quote-unquote safe right if anybody
could could issue it then someone could
write in some some JavaScript or
something and it could it could go south
really really fast so keep that in mind
but in this case we actually want it to
be HTML friendly so we want to display
it ok so the next thing is you might be
wondering hey that's not looking like
what we had in the admin 120 and then
there we go if we click on tutorial we
go to the print tutorial for example
what what happened to this beautiful
syntax highlighting that we had
what gives bro well what we need here is
some CSS cascading style sheet and also
some JavaScript so what we're gonna do
is bring in both and since we're at home
dot HTML we'll just do it all in this
same file so the first thing is for
statics so first of all the CSS already
exists it was when we grabbed the tiny
MCE app we actually got their CSS so
we're actually just gonna use theirs and
it's already here now to use something
from our static directory the first
thing we need to do is load static
unlike like flask for example if you're
familiar the static directory is always
accessible in flask whereas in Django if
you go to slash static you won't find a
directory there it's not like publicly
accessible basically all the stuff in
static is in Django accessible you're
just not gonna find a like a directory
structure like you would in flask
I'm sure you can hide it in flasks I
just it's never been important enough to
me to worry about it but anyways so now
what we want to do is we want to add
that style sheet so we're gonna add a
link here and in here is where we are
going to pass some more logics so again
just like this was logic here you can
also use logic in string form so in this
case this is kind of some weird logic
that you'll type nothing really else is
gonna act like this oh actually probably
what I want to do I think we would get
away with this actor way but I'm gonna
use single quotes here just so we don't
so the HTML itself doesn't look funky
but this is where we're gonna specify
the location so and this would be
already in a static directory just like
template static is loaded in the same
way it's slash static so again the
handling is no different than the way
that we handle for here right it's
already looking for a templates
directory so it's gonna look for the app
name and then the actual template the
same thing is true with static writes
app name and then if you had further
directories sure so okay so prism and
presumed CSS is the name of that
stylesheet and then we'll put rel
stylesheet okay so that's how we can
load in our actual stylesheet and in
fact this should probably be between
some head tags again this is not a HTML
tutorial if you don't know what this
kind of stuff means I encourage you to
go find an HTML tutorial this is just
the stuff that gets loaded like some
initial JavaScript if the JavaScript
needs to be loaded immediately anyways
CSS meta tags stuff like that it's gonna
go in the head then down here this is
like the body of so just like basically
everything the browser renders tends to
go into the body so this tab that stuff
over great
and then now we'll load it in some
JavaScript so
let's do script source source and again
we already have this as well this is the
Java scripts that will add our syntax
highlighting so static and again this is
tiny and in fact single quotes here tiny
and I think it's actually tiny MCE so
let me throw an MC here as well
tiny MCE js4 JavaScript and then prism
dot J s great and then we'll close off
the script tag okay let me save that
we'll come back to this in a moment if
this works cool if it doesn't work
anytime you got CSS or you're trying to
load anything with a path you can press
like f12 in at least in chrome and just
hit refresh and if there are if
something's not working the way that you
expect it to you'll probably have thrown
an error that you could come into
console and read most of the time it'll
be like hey I'm not finding something at
this location so yeah so in this case
everything appears to work we've got the
syntax highlighting yay congratulations
real briefly I know this is not an HTML
tutorial I just want to say sometimes
we're gonna load scripts in the head
sometimes we're gonna load them at the
end
in general you load JavaScript when you
need it in not a moment before right so
because the JavaScript is like with the
stylesheet you need to load that
immediately so the browser knows how to
style things underneath it with
JavaScript you can actually modify
things after the page has been loaded so
in general we'd like to load the page
first then worry about all the
JavaScript stuff that's why if you've
ever tried to parse something with
Python often if it's like a table that's
loaded with JavaScript
when you go to parse it with Python
there's like nothing in that table
because you made initially when you make
that request it doesn't actually
populate right it populates a little bit
after and that helps with like load
times and stuff like that so anyways
it's it's whenever you need it sometimes
you need it immediately sometimes you
don't so anyways here in this case we
don't need it immediately so we put it
at the bottom
okay so I think that's probably a good
stopping point things are pretty darn
ugly still and eventually we want to
have be able to have things like navbars
and buttons like clicking the login
button and and probably have the
tutorials themselves be styled in a
little bit different way I mean a lot of
thing like this is quite ugly I'm not
saying I'm a design genius or anything
but this is a little more pretty to look
at at least soon we've got all these
little functionalities and stuff like
that so what we're gonna be doing in the
next tutorial is talking a little bit
about design like I said I'm no artist
but what I tend to use is a CSS
framework called materialized CSS if we
were to check out oops not f12 see in
this case we've already got some things
is probably let's see is this for
something to do is Serge anyways I'll
have to look at that later view source
if we check we can see we've actually
got materialized on CSS here it is a
custom materialized CSS I'll show you
guys how to do that as well but anyways
that's what we're gonna be focusing on
the next tutorial is using a CSS
framework we'll really hopefully only
spend like one tutorial on all of that
you'll be expected to branch off on your
own if you want to learn more about
design that's not really the the purpose
of this series but it's not really fun
if our whole website looks like this
it's kind of trashy at this stage so
we'll get that fixed right up anyways
that's what I'll be doing the last
tutorial quick shout out to my most
recent channel members Thomas Randall
Erica Gomez Peyman agk and how Chang
thank you guys very much for your
support
lets me do what I love to do every day
so you guys are freaking awesome I will
see you guys in the next video